ces pigeons sont peut-être n'est plus
nombreux sur les toits de notre dame il
ne souhaite pas les mêmes ici les
gardiens du temple ce sont les faucons
plusieurs couple de rapaces y ont élu
domicile et règne sans partage
et ce n'est des darwin et des statuts un
site exceptionnel où les faucons peuvent
se reproduire et élever leurs petits en
toute tranquillité dans cette saison
donc on voit les couples en train
d'élever les jeunes les jeunes se
dispersent une fois qu'ils sont envolés
beaucoup de femelles également quitte
les sites de nidification à l'automne et
en hiver mais les mâles sont toujours là
et gardent leur territoire toute l'année
on peut voir des faucons crécerelles
toute l'année dans paris tour eiffel
sacré coeur ou arc de triomphe dans la
capitale une quarantaine et de kyushu et
de fonctions qui squattent ainsi les
monuments historiques et pour la
nourriture ces rapaces ont su s'adapter
à un milieu urbain alors leur
alimentation essentiellement occupé de
petits rongeurs qui peuvent souris
mulots campagnols également une part
d'oiseaux par exemple des moineaux
parfois quelques insectes bien qu'un et
très peu en région parisienne et sur
paris en raison de coûts des faits
étudiés depuis une quinzaine d'années
peu de personnes connaissent leur
existence pour les observer que trois
associations chaussures vont tout donner
à notre dame et mettre à disposition du
public
leur longue vue
alors c'est quoi enfin les regarder